[Music]
what's up Wolfgang if you are not aware
the licensing Expo is currently underway
in Las Vegas and at the licensing Expo
they released a new promo poster for
Aquaman and this promo poster revealed
to us that Aquaman has a brand new look
his new suit not only has a new look but
it looks like it has some armor upgrades
as well we'll be talking about his new
look in this video and the possibility
of the first trailer for Aquaman coming
out pretty soon but before we started if
you're new to this channel hit that
subscribe button and you'll be entered
into our speaker system giveaway and the
rest of the details for the giveaway are
in the description below so there are
obviously some major differences between
the suit that he was wearing in Justice
League and the suit that he's wearing in
this promo poster for starters it's not
a full suit it's not covering you know
every part of his body with the
exception of his hands it's only
covering a majority of his body you can
see where it's showing the stomach and
it's showing his arms and we can't see
the legs but it could possibly be
showing some of the legs as well so they
ditched the old green armor that kind of
looked like it had a bunch of scales all
over it and this seems to be more of a
natural Aquaman suit to me not in the
aspect of this is what it looks like in
the comics because obviously it's not
the old one looks more like the comics
and this one does but in the fact that
if I if there was a real-life Aquaman
I feel like this is what he would be
wearing it just sort of seems like it's
made from the sea it's just sort of
natural to me and it seems more
protective to me you can see on his
shoulders he's got armor there and he's
wearing a chest plate and he's got
protection over the top parts of his
legs on the sides as you can see right
below his belt there and it looks really
solid sturdy and strong I'd really hate
to take a shoulder charge from this guy
while he's behind those shoulder pads
but let's talk about the color this
armor is more orange than the armor that
he wore in Justice League and this may
be James Wan paying tribute to the
original suit from the comics well at
the same time keeping it realist
and that's the great thing about James
Wan he does keep it realistic I mean I
guess to the best you can when you're
talking about superheroes who live
underwater
and while we're on the topic of color it
looks like they kind of took the blond
out of his hair which is interesting
because it was a pretty big controversy
when Jason Momoa was cast as Aquaman a
Justice League because he doesn't have
really blonde hair like Aquaman does in
the comics and maybe this is them just
embracing the fact that hey okay he
doesn't have blonde hair but he's
Aquaman kind of deal with it we're not
gonna put a little bit of blonde in
there deal with it and one thing that I
did notice is the rings that he has on
his fingers he's wearing two and he
wasn't wearing any in Justice League my
first thoughts are that one is a radio
ring that he uses to communicate with
Mara or Queen Atlanta or arm and the
other I assume has the crest of Atlantis
on it or as a Royal heirloom or
something like that so that's a new suit
and it's been the first thing in a long
time that's been released to us about
Aquaman and it's exciting because it's
getting closer it comes out in December
at the end of this year and recently
there was footage of it shown at
CinemaCon last month and evidently it
was fantastic and there's been a lot of
talk about Aquaman saving the DCE you we
had a great refresher with Wonder Woman
that was awesome and then Justice League
came and it was not so good and there's
been a lot of talk about this a lot of
talk about Aquaman revitalizing it yet
again picking off from where Wonder
Woman left off with great DC movies
which you know we haven't had that many
yet and James Wan is a perfectionist so
I'm really excited to see his take on
this movie now it was said that the
footage that was shown last month at
CinemaCon was not finalized footage it
was unfinished
according to James Wan and was not meant
to be an official trailer for Aquaman
but apparently there is a rumor going
around at the licensing Expo that the
trailer for Aquaman will be released
within the next few weeks this lines up
because it comes out in December and the
movies that are coming out in November
the trailers for them were released this
week so it makes sense that the trailer
would be released in the next few weeks
because the movie
is released in December so that's it for
this video let me know what you guys
think of Aquaman's new suit that he's
wearing in this poster and let me know
if you think this is actually going to
be a good DC movie hopefully we can just
ignore Justice League and have Aquaman
be on the same level that Wonder Woman
was and just start with good DC EU
movies and hopefully we get the trailer
for Aquaman soon again let me know your
thoughts in the comments below and if
you enjoyed this video click that thumbs
up button for me and be sure to
subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date on the Aquaman DC and all things
superhero thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Music]